ich bin außerordentlich erleichtert dass
hier endlich ein bisschen
geschwindigkeit in die situation hinein
kommt die schnelltests sind von
hervorragender qualität sie sind einfach
durchzuführen und auch wenn sie bisher
nur unter ärztlicher aufsicht
durchführbar waren jeden intelligenten
menschen den ich getroffen habe konnte
ich innerhalb weniger minuten zeigen wie
das ganze geht die schnelltests sind gut
und sie sind dringend notwendig und ich
halte es auch für dringend notwendig
dass wir rasch ein system aufbauen dass
diese schnelltests für jeden leicht
zugänglich sind
ich werde also ganz dafür dass eine jede
apotheke leicht zugänglich diese
schnelltests anbieten kann
dass sie ein zertifikat ausstellen kann
damit man sich damit besser bewegen kann
dass es möglich wird damit grenzen zu
überschreiten und vieles anderes mehr
ich denke es ist höchste zeit und ich
bin froh dass endlich ein wenig
geschwindigkeit in dieses system hinein
kommt eines der argumente dass es jetzt
lange gab waren dass es vielleicht eine
falsche sicherheit durch diese
schnelltests geben kann wie genau sieht
das aus wenn ich jetzt den schnelltest
mache ist das eine momentaufnahme
inwiefern kann man sich dann sicher sein
dass man erstmal zumindestens niemanden
ansteckt also um dieses argument ist
auch vorgebracht worden aber es ist
nicht überzeugend die etablierten stellt
tests sind so dass er etwa 97 bis 98
prozent der fälle in denen eine klare
infektion vorliegt auch unmittelbar und
sofort erkannt werden und es macht doch
einen großen unterschied ob ich blind
bin oder ob ich 98,5 prozent vielleicht
der infizierten auch sofort
identifizieren kann ihnen helfen kann
dazu beitragen kann dass sie
anschließend durch eine weitere tester
in der pcr auch schnell sicherheit
bekommt also eine falsche falsch negativ
ist nicht das große problem denn selbst
in den fällen wo einmal falsch negativ
ist
sind es gerade solche fälle wo auch die
infektiosität geringer ist
also das ist kein wirkliches
gegenargument könnte man mit diesen
schnelltests auch schnell wieder ja
große events möglich machen oder
wenigstens vielleicht restaurantbesuche
nun kurzfristig solange die mutanten am
horizont stehen würde ich das vielleicht
nicht sagen mittel bis langfristig ganz
sicher ich glaube dass die schnelltests
auch dauerhaft ein wichtiger beitrag
dafür sein werden dass wir wieder zur
normalität zu bekommen und zur
normalität gehört daneben auch dass wir
wieder größere events feiern können und
was können diese tests für schulen und
kindergärten bedeuten auch trotz den
mutationen sehr sehr viel denn mit
diesen tests ist es möglich
beispielsweise eine aussage wie zwei mal
in der woche zu testen jedes kind jeden
lehrer jede lehrerin
ich denke dass es rasch realisierbar und
kann damit umgesetzt werden und wie
riesig die problematik des eröffnungs
von schulen sind das wissen wir doch
alle vielleicht gerade mit den neuen
mutanten
also ich glaube an den stellt es geht
nichts vorbei und wir sollten sie rasch
etablieren
und wir sollen sie auch rasch an den
schulen etablieren sowohl für die
lehrerinnen und lehrer als auch für die
schüler
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren